[Music]
in boys need love to news submitted by
fear of the unknown a mother responds to
critics who shame her for babying her
four-year-old son how can you baby a
four-year-old yeah it's a [ __ ] baby
well no it's not a baby it's a toddler
that's true
so don't title him what is she doing
that's I got a no this is the
breastfeeding she's still breastfeeding
then yeah these people should pick the
size pretty old is it bad to breastfeed
f4 Babbitt is just interesting
it's where the child could be like
mother can I have your tea in a
civilized society I think it's weird
normal biologically what like yeah like
breastfeeding societally or by Allah I
thought if the titty produced it then
you can suck on it biologically throw
that kid was like 11 what was like I
think with our busy lives societally and
what it might it might have changed and
sped up the process to like stop
breastfeeding earlier on in line now it
seems like it's a years okay so that's
kind of like the standard but what it do
you guys know what it used to be like oh
like you know my parents generation or I
think also biologically when you have
teeth you're supposed to start eating
[ __ ] oh and then when do teeth start
coming in first that's even like a year
right well before the knee before a year
but like your molars and stuff because I
like it when babies just have the front
tooth oh the Tigers still developing his
like he only has a couple molars so he's
probably gonna stop when he's like maybe
three but he already said no he's felt
like you or us feeding oh yeah not stop
until you get this molars yeah what the
[ __ ] are you an animal yeah I remember
the doctor told me like try to reach for
three months and then after three months
like if you don't want to or the baby
doesn't want to or then it's like a no
big deal but like the first three months
are like the golden milk like the
antibodies and all that good stuff you
know what else is good like
breastfeeding subscribing to this
channel that's what they should be knew
the doctor subscribed it Norrish am its
JK subscribed subscribe subscribe
alright so this girl her name is
katelyn she has an IG account and this
is where she posted her caption so she
says I'm so tired of being told I baby
my son remember since I had him he's
been a mama's boy now with him being
four he gets hurt he runs he runs crying
for mommy a little [ __ ] if you think
you want all the mom cuddles
he's overtired and fighting his sleep
I'm climbing into bed with him and so he
calms down
spineless just a dope mom I know right
I'm constantly told I need to let him be
a man or let him learn he can't where
does she live give him a briefcase
hey I agree with them [ __ ] little
tuxedo and give them a bomb the bus
ticket let's go figure it out I want to
read the rest for you
she says I'm constantly told I need him
too I need to let him be a man or learn
let him learn what the hell or let him
learn he can't cry well here I am
telling you at the load of [ __ ] he will
always be my baby I will always validate
his feelings he will always I will
always kiss his boo-boos better also has
proven that repressing children's
emotions never works out well later on
in life for them she should have been
like it's not my fault he's a little
[ __ ] who's telling her this is it like
a foster dad who's standing there
holding a [ __ ] can of beer that's
true continues I am teaching my kids
that their feelings are important that
they can cry when they are upset that
they can call on me anytime and I will
come running with arms open I'm teaching
that to both my daughter and son so I
will I will ignore your judgmental looks
I will ignore you telling me I baby him
too much I will ignore you telling me I
need to toughen him up he is my child he
is not weak or less than for showing
emotion and meeting me I'm raising him
to know men can cry two men can have
needs two men can get overwhelmed -
maybe if tearful little boys were
comforted instead of shamed we wouldn't
have so many men struggling to empathize
with emotions I don't care if a boy
cries but if the boy catches a ball like
this there is a little bit
[Laughter]
so is there any specific example of what
she did to make him a little [ __ ] I
read to you the knowledge yeah she
didn't give me examples I do know
there's an epidemic going on right now
called uh what is it like confidence
lifts men or there's like a term for it
basically it just means [ __ ] [ __ ]
weak little [ __ ] losers
I thought the terms millennial or
something there's insel there's all that
[ __ ] too well I mean you know we're
we're the end of the in cell generation
and on a lot of the older guys would say
that we're a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I and I have a theory I know my dad
thinks I'm a [ __ ] compared to anybody
of that generation we're [ __ ] yeah
yeah I mean my theory yeah I do oranges
my theory isn't is that the younger
generation are just always [ __ ]
regardless of exactly when yeah I don't
know any generation that the younger one
was tougher than the older because it's
always just gonna get easier and easier
and better cuz technology's better it's
more convenient
it's always something more like when I
was a kid I turn on the TV and buildings
are falling off the [ __ ] sky they're
falling out of the sky and planes are
[ __ ] crashing into buildings he
didn't have to worry about [ __ ] and we
will be able to say that and when was
when was it ever the opposite like when
the Great Depression happened right
we'll all of a sudden like the younger
men were a lot tougher than the older
men I don't know or World War two all
the men that got drafted
were they tougher than the older men
that didn't get drafted right like I
don't I don't know why any Gerry that's
what progress looks like right like so I
got Society gets better like obviously
we reap the benefits of that yeah it's
like having glasses like technology got
better so people with poor I say can
survive and they like get to wear
glasses and like see things and stuff
but it makes their eyes weaker because
they doesn't make you a [ __ ] right just
could see better yeah because it's
progressed its progression you have now
have technology you don't have to rely
on natural good eyesight my son is gonna
be able to get his dick sucked by a hot
robot yep and that is cool but also it's
kind of like hey man like I don't know
that's a little bit of
let's move like it is shouldn't be
having these robots I could identify the
human maybe to do it yeah we had to like
hunt for women that way hope that they
went for it I think people that need a
little bit of adversity to make them a
strong character wise but there's like a
like what's it called like a controlled
adversity right we're like you they get
enough to toughen them up and like hold
strong as an individual in a person but
I like a child four years old absolutely
he's allowed to crowd think he should
man up a little bit he look a little bit
of a person I was raised boys and girls
were raised to say in that sense I
wasn't allowed to cry unless I was hurt
because you had a asian daddy yeah and I
had so many repressed emotions and
abandonment issues and stuff that had to
work out there look at where you are
today I cry all the time he's just cried
this morning I cried this word because I
was too happy but you're doing well for
yourself what did the mom do that
everyone is like so against her yeah I
don't know they don't really she doesn't
go into detail is just the fact that so
her whole page
it's just her showing the kid love she's
putting her son and Patagonia vest in
[ __ ] dude come on just raise a little
[ __ ] boy she's a young mom and so like
she ends up posting a lot of her
Instagram about like things that she
wants to not be so taboo anymore so like
she tries like she didn't even post
photos of like her stretch marks and
like she's she's really like open and
like real she struggles with like mental
health stuff too like she has severe
anxiety so that's her whole thing like
her whole page is just she says posting
with a purpose so like that's that's how
she communicates with like that's how
she uses her Instagram so the shoot this
was just another aspect of her life her
parenting yeah experience that she just
wanted to address and be like listen I
am gonna validate my son's feelings a
lot of people seem to have this idea
this notion that boys can't be babied or
they shouldn't show their emotions so
she's just pointing that out that's like
her whole page but see I don't we're
where's the men our baby a lot like what
a lot like it's too much yeah cuz like
I'm like my mom will like full night
brother's laundry like she's and he's
like 27 and stuff like he he's still I
feel like boys are treated you were
talking about with Isaac like boys are
still treated
this certain way we're like the moms
want to take care of them and then the
girls are trained to do everything on
their own so they can future take care
of their husbands everyone needs a
grandpa I was like where's she from they
said UK [ __ ] then we are your job as a
grandfather is to [ __ ] make some men
out of these little [ __ ] that's why
I'm out man cuz I don't have any grandpa
I didn't my dad's in a bad job well yeah
he like he thinks I'm a [ __ ] for sure
yeah but he'll do anything for Tiger
mm-hmm I watched my grandpa died in
horrible horrible agony and pain and he
still wouldn't cry in front of me damn
that guy's a [ __ ] back best
I've never seen anybody look down on
someone for showing a little boy
affection but I see I remember I've
gotten that why for showing him but it
but here's the point though when what I
have seen is when you don't make the
little boys accountable for their
actions
and yeah so the whole affection thing I
can relate to because for in Japanese
culture at least for my mom's generation
once the kid boy starts going to school
you stop you stop showing physical
affection so you your affection changes
in a different way but that's about
building character and strength and it's
a warrior society so in that sense you
have to do it in a way where you have to
start separating physically because they
see that is still sucking on your mom's
titty it's different it's like yeah
because if you're just hugging and
holding on to her it's a security
blanket and they're like you need to be
an independent man and you can't run to
your [ __ ] mommy every time you you
need something so they see hugging and
touching as that in that time you vote
for me when I had Nicky over at my
grandpa's house and my grandpa would try
to kiss her on the lips and then I
couldn't even hug him because you know I
still know
cry I really want to beat this one yeah
he's gone he's gone didn't meet think
you went like this yeah so in way more
pain oh my god thanks for the reminder
my other grandpa had one of those holes
in his throat I'm smoking from smoking
so much yeah and he died like two years
after I was born
yeah cuz like when I think of like hard
military culture grandpa's like that and
I could totally picture that I just
maybe it's like la white people right
it's hella soft and whatever I just see
it totally different side because when I
think about Bible Belt white people
conservative I can picture that like
that hard grandpa that's cussing up a
storm and he's like is the
overcompensating over here we have a lot
of over overcorrected you know you're
the kids of that that ran away and
they're like I'm gonna [ __ ] pursue my
dreams of being an LA and then they want
to run away from all that [ __ ] and
change it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]